encore un nouveau venu à la chanson ce
mois ci c'est julien clerc julien tu as
21 ans bernard oui tu écris tes chansons
non je fais les musiques et j'ai deux
paroliers tu as abandonné des études non
non je continue je fais ma licence
d'anglais sûr mais surtout pas pour
enseigner c'est peut-être pour faire 10
du journalisme un jour pour moi pour mes
parents c'était pour sciences po et
éventuellement l'énam enfin les n'avait
été écartée depuis longtemps par mois il
est arrivé que j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer
une cousine qu'avait un frère qui était
donc mon cousin à cousin que j'ignorais
que directeur artistique dans une maison
de disques
on se l'est le voir je suis allé là bas
coup de chance
je vais faire du piano pascal erre doué
pour la musique il a toujours chanté
très cher d'ailleurs tous les enfants
chanter en public c'était un mariage
genre points suivants
c'était hier la première publique de m
ça se passe comme ça c'est la première
publique de m ça veut dire cheveux ou
poils des cheveux font pas poil ras des
chiens en nickel c'est pour le sauver de
la taxe sur les affiches a marqué la
troupe française de air et non pas
troupes françaises de poêle avec
d'accord quand j'ai vu des gens partir
du moment où il faisait air se met des
plumes et des ceintures et des et des
pantalons en daim ça m'a mis en colère
s'est mis en colère parce que il ya
quelque chose qui cloche et qui ne s'est
pas passé comme ça aux etats unis c'est
la cc cette question là c'est cette
question d'esprit le jeune français qui
ne fumait pas on ne fait rien qu'ils
aient mis à fumer après sa manière en
colère parce que c'est en désaccord avec
l'esprit même de la pièce l'esprit de la
pièce est justement son naturel d'être
soi même sûrement
est-ce que vous avez un grand projet un
premier spectacle oui je projette 8,4 un
an et demi deux ans explose d'épopée
musicale parce qu'il ya déjà une idée
des ouïes une idée des parm du départ
les secrets je préfère qu'elle le reste
alors